welcome back this is the ben shapiro
show so obviously the eyes of the nation
remain fixed on serve side where a
building collapse has left approximately
people missing uh at this point it
appears that
the the hopes of finding anybody alive
are very very slim
at this point it seemed slim frankly
from the beginning given the way that
the building collapsed
joining us on the line to disgust is
jimmy petronis he's the chief financial
officer and state fire marshal
for the state of florida and a member of
florida's cabinet he oversees the
department of financial services as well
as the urban search and rescue teams for
the entire state jimmy thanks so much
for joining the show really appreciate
it
thanks ben appreciate all you do so why
don't we start with just the update from
surfside uh i know that there is talk of
hope remaining for the
the possibility that maybe there's a
pocket in which people
are still living but that hope has to be
waning at this point so
um we're we're into day seven uh
there's as many resources on the ground
here
working on a one acre site as there was
working
for the entirety of hurricane michael
which was a cat
5 storm that hit 12 counties in
northwest florida
totally different battle rhythm uh the
men and women here they
they they're not used to working elbow
to elbow uh
one task force might but all eight of
them are working elbow to elbow on a one
acre site so
um the emotion um and the passion that
they've got is inspiring
um i i tell people that that's a common
question you know
does this change to recovery instead of
rescue and i told them i said these
teams aren't built that way
they're built for rescue that's why
these task force
teams have embedded trauma surgeons they
have embedded
engineers they're they are built to save
lives so we are
we are still uh incredibly optimistic um
and uh when really with with task force
one and task force two
that's miami-dade county city of miami
you can imagine they're
incredibly emotionally compromised
because of loved ones
that are affected or in the building and
that
creates an incredible amount of emotion
and momentum
for the other task forces so jimmy uh
obviously
uh there's obviously been a lot of
questions on social media about
why does the stuff move so slowly and i
that that obviously is because
none of us in sort of the civilian
population really understand how this
sort of stuff works we just see a big
pile of stuff we're like why can't they
just go remove all the stuff so maybe
you can walk us through some of the
obstacles that are that are faced by the
the rescue teams
in going through the debris sure sure
and uh
uh knowing you because i'm a loyal
listener i'm sure you've you've unpacked
it all
because you do your homework but but
these uh uh just to try to make it as
easy as it can for for your your
listeners um
the the debris that they're moving um if
you can imagine
a stack of pancakes but they're made out
of concrete
those though they have to be removed
level by level
um the part of the problems you've got
is the pieces
have to be cut by hand with uh concrete
saws but here's another challenge the
concrete saws that they're using
they're used to being used you know
maybe
20 minutes at once or maybe 10 minutes
at once
these things are running hours at a time
so so the the type of
of effort and the battle rhythm is is
more intense
that's ever been seen in the history of
state of florida so
you know what we're we're overnighting
equipment we're not going to allow these
guys to do without the equipment
earlier today as they worked through the
night
they were actually able to build a ramp
in order to get
heavy equipment down on scene as opposed
to working from the outer edges
that equipment only has so much of an
extension to be able to do their job
but now as you've been able to build a
ramp to get in you can actually move
some of these pieces you can move some
of these pieces
uh that could weigh 25 000 pounds where
they would have to have been cut down to
10 000 pounds
by hand in order for the crane to do it
just because of just
simple physics um so uh you know it's uh
it's extraordinarily challenging there
and then
which also adds to complications there
was some video released by miami fire
rescue today that i thought was very
helpful we've been very protective
over the videos are being released
simply because of the sensitive nature
but so much is being done by hand with
bucket
we are having to sort through personal
effects debris
uh anything that could potentially be
of an attachment to a family member um
i was talking to to one of the first
responders who uh who found a
birthday card with butterflies on it um
that card is being saved you know those
that's the type of
sensitivity that these men and women are
doing at the same time working at a
breakneck speed
to save lives so jimmy from what
direction are the rescuers working and
they're working from underneath from the
sides from the top how many layers of
the
of the concrete have they gotten through
we're talking about you know 12 stories
that collapsed how many layers are they
through at this point
so uh i have not gotten the update from
today of what floor they're on
as of yesterday they had gotten down to
the ninth floor we're talking about a
12-story building
uh part of the challenge has been is is
the way the building i'm sure y'all seen
how the building fell
but that center column that spell first
and then the the last column itself so
one is on top of the other
so that ad adds some challenges um
the other is you've got a building that
is uh
structurally compromised that is still
standing um
an enormous amount of the debris that is
pushed up against that
building right now the engineers uh feel
like
that is kind of a safety blanket there
there's a 40-foot buffer
all around the base of the building that
they're staying away from
there's there's air conditioning units
that are clinging to hanging to the side
of the building
they call those air-conditioned units
widowmakers
because of what could happen of an item
that weighs you know
600 pounds thousand pounds drops on
somebody
below it so so unfortunately that area
there is off-limits
but it also provides a real sense of
comfort
uh to the engineers that that's what
keeps the building at bay
while they work on everything to the
most eastern
side of the site so jimmy final question
for you what is the actual timeline
of being able to get through all this
stuff we've been going at this for for a
week at this point
and as you mentioned as of yesterday
they were through floor nine uh so what
what is the actual timeline on the full
excavation of the site
so so these guys are going to get into a
battle rhythm as they have been
um you know they are going to um as
they hit boots on the ground there's a a
a
series of steps they can they can you
know anticipate are going to have to be
taken
in order to continue to get to the next
for the next four unfortunately
this is what this is what is so um so
it's so challenging about it water is
both good
and bad rain is both good and bad um
whenever fire strikes it it
essentially shuts down the site that
that that loses incredibly valuable time
because now you're you're moving a
mission to putting out a fire
so you can continue the life-saving
mission uh in addition
when you dump water onto the site from
fire hoses
that adds hundreds and hundreds of
pounds of weight
to the system that ultimately has to be
pumped out um
you can't control mother nature we've
got some weather system it's almost
rained
every single day so all that also
changes
what can be the you know the kind of the
expectation you know they they're
usually good about
as we were kind of just gauging it uh
about they can get to
get to a floor about once every two days
but now you put a
you know a 200 ton crane on site more
intimately into the rubble
now you are able to speed up that
timeline so so
you know really the the time they can be
finished is a little bit of a moving
target
the other concern you get is um
they want to get to the debris field
that is up against the building because
uh it's it's it's their mission
um unfortunately they can't deal with
that unless they can secure the building
that's standing
it's almost impossible to do that
without
you know some type of uh either removal
or or you know demolition of the
building that's standing because
it is so incredibly unstable so uh
jimmy i wanted to ask you also a little
bit about the the
source of the collapse obviously this is
the big question a lot of people are
worrying
uh living in high rises on the coast
because there are tons of them in miami
about the structural safety of their
buildings it seems like there are some
complicating factors with this
particular building there have been some
reports of structural unsoundness going
back years it now appears that the
the hoa is is sometimes happens i had
been putting off
major spends on on structural support uh
do
do is the going theory right now uh that
this was
a sinkhole due to natural conditions or
that this was
failure to do the necessary upkeep at
the bottom of the building to maintain
the structural integrity or that this
was just a flawed original build
so so you know there there are you know
earnest efforts taking place right now
between um like the mayor uh earlier
this week
he has taken every document that that
condo has ever mentioned
and is having it all pulled in and put
in a public place
so anybody that wants to look whatever
the city has on file regarding that
building
inspections permits you name it it's
available for review
uh the county has instituted a in
in dade county different date county
already had an ordinance in place that
any building at 40 years has to have a
mandatory building inspection
to make sure the stability and health of
the building so this building was built
in the early 1980s
it was on that threshold of where it
needed to have its inspection
and then the county has the ability to
basically
force these buildings to make these type
of inspections
depending on if they needed to be
condemned or not so the county what i
thought was smart
they went ahead and did an emergency
order and are forcing inspections of all
buildings
that are anywhere remotely near that so
that is taking place right now to try to
get some comfort
to those that are concerned um but as uh
as we found out
uh yesterday at april yesterday uh the
local state attorney
is convening a grand jury uh they're not
going to take any chances
to make sure that people uh can get to
the bottom of the answers
and if somebody needs to be held
accountable that they'll be held
accountable
jimmy from the street financial officer
state fire marshall really appreciate
your time
and of course uh good luck and best
wishes and thank you to everybody
uh who's working on on this crisis it
obviously is a
tragedy of horrific proportions and and
people who are working in dangerous
conditions to
uh attempt to both uncover what happened
and alleviate it we're really grateful
to everybody doing that
ben if i can hold you for one more
second just because uh the first
responders here the 400 of them
here they don't they don't listen to the
news right now they don't listen to the
radio
but what they do is they call home and
their family members
listen to your show and i just want to
share with you to them
to get back they call home and they
check with their wives
they are the most amazing superheroes
i've ever seen in my entire life
and um i'm so honored to be a citizen of
the state of florida i'm so
in awe of their determination and
passion to do everything possible to
save lives
and uh you know what their their their
moms and dads and their spouses at home
should be very proud jimmy agreed and
really appreciate your time and theirs
as well thank you so much
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content